o
hier hier sitzen die jungen leute die
rentner von morgen und schaukeln sich
ihre jingle bells lehre erloschene
gesichter hallo ihr werdet gerade
beschissen wisst ihr was die coco für
euch drin lässt im händen sack zwei
nüsse und eine alte mandarine hier weil
ab 2030 die baby boomer in rente gehen
die geburtenstarken jahrgänge verwöhnt
feiste typen wie der da die kino rente
ihr seid die gekniffenen und macht nix
das ist ein los mit euch stadt für eure
zukunft interessiert ihr euch nur für
handytarife oder das neue sack irrsinn
von justin bieber
morgen
der österreicher krieg nur deutlich
höhere rente weil da fast alle in die
kasse einzahlen und der arbeitgeber
anteil höher ist als was österreicher
schaffen kann jeder schaffen gut du
wahrscheinlich nicht da bin ich mir die
schlaffe körpersprache da angucke für
eure generation gibt es nur eine
hoffnung dass eingefrorene rentenniveau
das geht so wenn europa stirbt dann sagt
ihr einfach keinen bescheid legt ihn in
die kühltruhe und kassiert weiter seine
welt und jetzt lasse ich mich von zwei
opas zum nordpol ziehen
die sind viel billiger als rentiere
[Applaus]